okay I've looked around how're you were
sort of getting there some of your very
confusing your equation for D let's
scoot this is a go shall we
I tried to make it as obvious as
possible this is just a right-angled
triangle okay
so D comes from Pythagoras yeah so
you're gonna get this d squared is equal
to these two sweat yeah take this up
okay so you're getting a 100 minus 32
all squared right plus 100 minus 40 T
whole square okay now after you simplify
that out and we just don't shake the
numbers you're gonna get a quadratic
yeah
because you've got huge numbers I'm
gonna take out a factor of a hundred and
I think what you're left with is still
something quite large 25 G squared minus
140 T plus 200 check out hope so yeah
now that's an equation for D squared not
a whole lot of used to become different
she though right so you take the square
root
don't miss this but you're just dealing
with algebra here right so even though
you know it's a distance you can't just
go to the positive value straight away
you guys know this okay you're gonna
disregard something you've got to
provide the reason so snap your plus or
minus or on the front I'll put the
hundred out the front because it's
square and the rest of it comes
underneath the square root okay
now like I said you want disregard when
the values do remember to say Y is
greater than zero it's a link now we can
go from here okay this when I've got a
positive value is something I can
differentiate whenever Justin's ready
thank you going now it's it's that peril
huh there's not really make sure cus you
can take it you're gonna use chain rule
yeah
so I'm just gonna make that a little
more obvious to the power huh okay and
by the way this is one of the reasons
why it's worthwhile not to just write y
- D - that kind of thing we're
differentiating with respect to a
specific variable so say what you're
differentiating has been to D capital D
on the detail okay all right even you
taught to write simple chain rule what
do I start with
turns out the front no what okay I've
brought the power hold on listen up
times a half brother tap power down at
the front okay then this stays the same
but power goes down by one okay now what
okay I'm gonna do the I've just done the
outside so now I'm going to the inside
25 T squared is going to become 140 T
will become okay so far so good
yep all right now before we go any
further okay I could do some work here
to simplify it but what am i after I'm
just after turning points right now
remember that this part in here cuz it's
got a negative index right it's gonna go
in the denominator so I always don't
need to worry about it
right because what I'm gonna really ask
for at any point is the numerator being
equal to zero okay that's gonna give me
a stationary point I'm gonna have to
test it okay let's just tie this up a
little bit of the square root hundred it
looks good
don't get intimidated by it okay what do
I have on the top
see your 50 outside of was it five t- o
five here and you've taken out a factor
of ten right for take Stella Kevin yeah
okay now just because of money a bit of
a room I'm not gonna write the whole
thing but you guys know what to do now
potential turning points okay I'm not
interested in stage anyway something yes
what are you looking at
I've just gotten to five from here five
from there and a 10 from them pulled it
out his wife Christine that okay yep
I'm actually not interested in you know
I could get out the number but I just
want this part here that's gonna use to
solve it in a second okay so I'll say
potential ten points occur where this
derivative is equal to zero okay
ie when T is equal to two
right what is it I think it's 1400 and
five which is 2.8 I think okay now this
is an obvious one right I have to test
it to show that it's actually to any
point so what shall I used to test the
first or second what a jerk okay I'm
gonna his first what a troll
I'm not differentiate again that's
that's pretty close to see that's great
you'll be a wonderful engineer one day
so take your value you fatigue it's a
question so on a waiter right so two
point eight ideally I think here we want
to go two point seven two point nine
okay okay now you get some numbers in
here right I'm not particularly anxious
than what they are right now I'm
interested in the method but just please
actually get a number in these places
okay once you get them therefore you are
going to indeed sure but this is a
minute
and that's what we were after
right so the time is two point eight
hours and if the question asks you could
work out okay what is the actual
distance between them I think it works
out to be twenty kilometers at that
point okay now why did I draw this
question out part of the previous one
which is a really gross of similarity
one the thing about this is that you
have to be so careful in what you're
saying as your actual variables it's all
in the set up the rest of this it's all
just mechanical okay but if you get this
part wrong if you just call this why you
just call it X you just go around and
around in circles or triangles okay so
be careful